[Music]
on the Italian island of Sardinia there
is a delicacy that has been consumed for
thousands of years it is known as the
world's most dangerous cheese yeah you
heard right
[Music]
meet Simona IVA a third-generation sheep
farmer demo chick the chanchan
quantization top a current approval
changmo last request ona party questo
lot a lute Elysium fr Adele formaggio
kazuma's kazoo marzu literally means
rotten cheese and it's not for the faint
of heart because this cheese is infested
with thousands of live maggots and while
that might seem a bit off-putting at
first it's the maggots that give the
cheese its distinctive texture and
flavor here's how it works
first a traditional wheel of pecorino
cheese is made from sheep's milk then a
special fly called a cheese fly is
allowed to lay its eggs in it in the
journey la forma será completamente in
basel de las calles are at the lacewing
larvae over the course of two three
months the maggots eat the cheese and
then excreted out again transforming it
into the soft and creamy
Kazu Marzu / support began in sephora
reverse Gustav passed also la voce fala
monster today it's a favorite for
special occasions like weddings and
birthday parties but eating this cheese
can be dangerous second local coudl very
continuous evil internal nanak hosi say
no sorry mo PA de vere me no but can
imagine mode on Evita
even though cases like this are
extremely rare it's risky enough that
the cheese is illegal to sell the
farmers like Simona continue to make it
for themselves
don't poke aquila get fun on college for
money much but our loss and promo shoot
on your non lucano shoot mean only in
the Hz and they just can't get enough
for much a match for prosciutto 1580
Milan la morte soon
you
cork it's the miracle tree bark that's
found in everything from baseball bats
to spaceships but it's best known as the
last obstacle in your journey to drink
wine yes sometimes decor can can feel
like a chore no I'm not talking about
popping up in a wine bottle I'm talking
about how cork is harvested in the first
place by these guys manual cork
harvesters in Portugal it's a job so
difficult and yet so artful machines
have yet to render an absolute welcome
to Portugal where cork is the national
tree cork is native to the Mediterranean
Basin but nowhere does it grow more than
here part of all have 35% of all our
trees in the world history needs a very
special conditions of humidity and hot
weather since cork trees can live for
200 years
Gonzales trees are the exact same trees
his parents grandparents and
great-grandparents also care for
[Music]
the pork harvesting is a process that
can only be done by hand the man's work
always in team of tools first they cut
the tree like Taylor they draw the tree
with several cards to open the cork when
they threw the axe they also twist the
hand to open the cork after that with
the side of the blade they will open and
super the cork from the tree
[Music]
comics Tom desert
sighs I talk about pork and adequate
water concurrent across color confirm is
considered odd sheersha grams of
interior compartment compartments Gustad
[Music]
STM passenger a sample jarasandha Evod
manera de sin the pillows coarseness our
spoon of free deserve along distance
toad shock mudo for Escada the carrot
Madeira sauce Taral menu
the men's learn from quite young to just
cut the cork and doesn't get the lair of
the cork tree if the men get the lair
that's a problem they will harm the tree
and open and enters for bugs and other
disease
[Music]
once a tree is harvested it won't be cut
again for another nine years this keeps
the bark healthy and the harvest
tradition alive for the generations to
come to all our generations we take care
of our trees like we take care of our
sons this is very important for us let's
say your cheese producer and you need a
loan because you want to buy a tractor
or food for your cows or really just
about anything there's a bank in Italy
that will take your cheese and give you
cash this is the story of three men and
millions of dollars worth of cheese meat
mouth Tom he's a cheese producer in the
emiliano region of Italy he produces
parmigiano-reggiano the so-called king
of cheese 3000 wheels holy cow that's a
lot of cheese when matter or another
cheese producer in this part of Italy
needs a loan they go to create Emiliano
a big Italian bank and like any bank
elite Emiliano needs collateral for the
loan cosy yearly dunya for Mad Dog and
to do that he talks to Fausto ciao he
works for credit Emiliano Yamuna Bank a
traditional h'mong Kuna banker Viva a
sustained oh they purgatory the
parmigiano Reggiano parmigiano Reggiano
is a special kind of cheese because it
needs to be aged for 18 to 36 months and
will to be worth thousands of dollars
make me the safe long-term investment
for the bank the Chula Vista little
parmigiano-reggiano pero esto tipo de
programa de Gracia a simplemente the
root alpha took a crystal product or
traditional meant a typical parody ran a
theme for 40 quasi una Corda questa
territorial to be clear the bank doesn't
store the valuable cheese in its vaults
next to gold bars and stacks of cash
they have a special cheese warehouse
down the road
with thousands and thousands of wheels
of cheese that's why Roberto comes in
he's a general director of the tagliata
general warehouses
that's where credit emiliano stores
their cheese Mucha Pena bakura will form
a super Cordova cliente revert to his
team take care of more than three
hundred thousand wheels of cheese that's
currently worth more than 160 million
euros without proper care cheese closest
value titanium all investing means au de
la tienda product reach a queenly bala
mool Covino alabanza
well roberto sounds to me like the cow
the bank and the cheese aren't good
hands the average visitor Anapa
doesn't look vineyards and think of barn
owls
[Music]
they think of wine and wine tasting but
owls are really part of this whole
process walking up to an owl box and
hearing the babies hissing is pretty
scary sounding and then you just pull
out this little fluffy owl they're gonna
grow up to be wrote it devouring
machines my name is Kerry went I'm a
wildlife biologist I was in the last
couple years driving around visiting
hundreds of al boxes on 65 vineyards in
Napa Valley to better understand how
barn owls and vineyards can coexist
without owls the rodent population would
explode and they would cause a lot more
damage to vineyards so here's a couple
of skull they pulled out of the box this
is proof that they're eating rodents
using barn owls to reduce rodent
populations on vineyards is the
alternative way to kill rodents grow up
to be big and strong
eat lots of Gophers the mainstream
conventional way of killing rodents is
to apply rodenticides
the rodenticides are really harmful so
using owls is definitely the sustainable
eco-friendly way to reduce rodents you
have to have a special permit to have
these bands and to be able to band birds
each band is an individual number so
it's an individual identification for
that one bird that won't ever be on a
different bird my colleagues are
currently using GPS tags
and motion-detecting cameras to paint a
fuller picture of how barn elves may
provide pest control services and
vineyards we're banding them to see
where they're nesting when we capture
the adult birds to put GPS trackers on
them we want them to stay as calm as
possible so we put an adorable hat over
their eyes you don't put them over we
found this silly owl hat and he thought
it was perfect
[Music]
there are so many opportunities for
vineyard owners to enhance wildlife
habitat on their vineyards that's
mutually beneficial and I think
providing barn owl nest boxes on
vineyards is a perfect example of how
that relationship can flourish
[Music]